today on the matt wall show thanksgiving
is tomorrow and this shouldn't be
necessary it shouldn't come to this but
i will offer my defense of celebrating
thanksgiving explain why
uh i'll still be gathering with my
family for the holidays and i don't see
any problem with it at all in fact i
think it's the right thing to do also
five headlines including the media going
back into fawning mode now that they're
anticipating a democrat in the white
house also some employees at random
house
apparently broke down in tears when they
found out that the publisher was putting
out a jordan peterson book
is there ever any acceptable reason to
cry at work we'll talk about that and in
our daily cancellation
i will be canceling one of the most
sinister groups in america
that would be cyclists all of that on
the way
before we get to any of that a quick
word from lifelock you know with holiday
season upon us we're spending a lot of
time online we're doing some online
shopping
and all that sort of thing uh your
online data
is more vulnerable than ever around the
holiday season
you know the thing with the thing is
cyber criminals very tricky
um scumbags and they can often hide
malware in
emails these deceptive emails can look
like real invoices
invites payment information there's a
document attached and the attachments
can
contain text and images that look
completely legitimate and then when you
click on them
pop-up appears prompting you to enable
content or
enable editing but if you do this the
attachment will
will install malware on your computer
and this is something that you know as i
always say it's
it's even even if you you're looking out
for the
the nigerian prince sort of typical scam
they've been doing for 20 years
um but a lot of these in a lot of cases
it's a lot more clever than that and
some of these emails can look
very legitimate it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives this
holiday season
you could miss certain identity threats
if you're just monitoring your credit
look at your bank statements and that
sort of thing
get lifelock it's the leader in identity
theft protection
lifelock helps detect a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number being for sale on the
dark web
if they detect your information is is
compromised or being used in their
network
they're going to send you an alert and
and listen if you also have a problem
and uh and your identity is compromised
they're also going to have people there
to help you with that nobody can prevent
all identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but life
lock can help
and help you especially this holiday
season feel warm and protected
save up to 25 off your first year at
lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off now this week uh of course many of
our nation's most
dangerous fugitives will meet in their
localized criminal cells to
share in an illicit meal and plot to
destroy human civilization that second
part is admittedly speculation as for
the rest the media along with various
governors across the country
and our trusted public health
authorities have made it clear that
anyone who gathers with their family for
a traditional thanksgiving dinner
this year is engaging in something
approaching biological terrorism
so just for a taste of this
fear-mongering here's a compilation put
together
by grabbing media and this is just all
the different
people in the media explaining how
dangerous it is to
celebrate thanksgiving listen uh this
thanksgiving is gonna suck a bit
this is not some existential reality
cancel your plans if you
absolutely do not need to travel
somewhere travel by car
if you must travel i don't like it to be
any number
i like it to be keep it to your
immediate household eat all of the
mashed potatoes
by yourself that's what i'm gonna do
limit the number of people
do it outside and wear your mask if you
go over
to a friend's house mask up the whole
time you're not eating or drinking
your college student shelter in place
for at least seven days
once you arrive separation should be the
norm
avoiding direct contact including
handshakes and hugs speak softer
because louder voices shouting screaming
actually
singing spreads the virus so you can't
test your way out of or
into safety here you can't test your way
to thanksgiving dinner i mean you just
can't test your way to that table that's
just not the way
you can't test your way into
thanksgiving dinner having one person
serve
all the food so multiple people are not
handling the serving utensils and open
the windows if you can or have the air
blowing out
do a lot of face time or zooming i'll be
there
virtually but not personally assume
thanksgiving is a lot better than an icu
christmas cancel
your plans cannot be more clear here
invite
grandma this could be her last
thanksgiving yeah if you invite her to a
place where she can get sick and die
people who don't want to miss out on
their next family event of thanksgiving
should watch that segment again because
what you really don't want is your next
family event
to be a funeral yes as you can hear
warnings have been issued with
dramatic flair to keep our thanksgiving
celebrations relegated to our immediate
households
uh eat all of your mashed potatoes by
yourself as we heard the one
msnbc talking head urge and what what
you really don't want is for your next
family event to be a funeral
says the other laying it on especially
thick now some states have
banned private gatherings of more than
10 people pretending that every home in
america is the same size and has the
same capacity
governor cuomo author of one of these
bans says that if you love your family
you'll stay away from them and here's
governor cuomo giving us a lecture on
the true meaning of love
it's your family it's your home
it's your table these are all
environments where you
feel safe and that is the beauty of
thanksgiving
i'm at home with my family i'm in my
safe zone your safe zone
is not a safe zone your safe zone
is dangerous this year please
love is sometimes doing what's hard
this year if you love someone
it is smarter and better to stay
away now as per usual cuomo was not
planning on following his own advice
they never do he had invited his
89 year old mother to his home for
thanksgiving
apparently he doesn't love her i guess
he doesn't love his own mother at least
according to his own logic
but he reversed course on that and
disinvited his mother
after the public noticed and pointed out
the hypocrisy
meanwhile um the cdc has issued its own
guidelines recommending that everybody
wear a mask at thanksgiving presumably
i don't know i guess you would take the
mask off to eat at least
though perhaps you could keep it on and
attempt to absorb your food through a
process of osmosis
the cdc also asks that we keep our music
down
and talking to a minimum lecturing the
public like
chaperones on a middle school field trip
but you know the advice about keeping
the music down around the holidays is
pretty good i think you know there's a
real concern that if the coronavirus
is forced to hear a song like last
christmas by wham
it might decide to infect everyone in
the house out of revenge you know you
never know
it's science it has happened yet in
spite of all these rules
laws prohibitions pleadings warnings a
significant portion of americans are
still going about their thanksgiving
business as usual more than three
million people traveled by plane this
past weekend
in the lead-up to the holiday polls show
that the media fear-mongering has
successfully convinced many to forego or
modify their plans but that millions of
others
will still be seeing their families i
will be in this latter group
and although i resent the idea that
gathering with my own family for a meal
should require
any defense at all i will give one
anyway
um i can't very well let the only
psychotic grandma killers will have a
normal thanksgiving this year narrative
be the only one presented so here is why
in spite of the risk however mild or
severe it might be
i will still be celebrating with my
family two reasons really and they're
very simple
this is all it comes down to number one
and i want to be so clear about this i
don't care
what anyone in the media or the
government says or thinks
on the subject of thanksgiving or any
other subject for that matter
the panic porn fails to make an impact
with me and so many others because
it's being pushed by people who have
thoroughly discredited themselves
forfeited their credibility lockdown
governors and mayors attend birthday
parties they dine
masculists at restaurants while
condemning or banning the same behavior
from citizens blm radicals riot in the
streets democrats dance and celebration
after the election
these activities are condoned even
encouraged by the people now telling us
that the only safe way to observe
thanksgiving is to sit alone at our
empty table
gorging on a family-sized portion of
mashed potatoes mashed potatoes
why should anything these people say
matter why should we pay it any mind at
all
consider also that walmarts and targets
and other big box retailers
are going to be open for black friday
shopping the day after thanksgiving
as they have been open throughout the
entire kovic crisis they never shut down
we are expected to believe that you know
cramming our carts full of consumer
electronics and other junk made in china
is a perfectly pandemic safe activity
and it's on this basis that the
lockdowns have transferred
billions of dollars from small
businesses to these mega corporations
all of which
have reaped enormous profits while
smaller firms have been wiped out in
mass and it's interesting to me by the
way that
you know the people who are so critical
of the evil corporations have
said nothing about this historic
transfer of wealth
from small businesses and middle class
people to
big corporations but what really makes
walmart safe quote unquote is that it's
a very rich
powerful well-connected company
it exerts its influence with those who
make the rules in ways that your local
shops on mainstream cannot so
main street cannot so your local shops
on main street
are destroyed while walmart walmart
amazon
and target and others feast on their
carcasses
this of course a process has been going
on for many decades but the lockdowns
have accelerated
the process to a staggering and
catastrophic degree
and it all underscores the point that
again the people making the rules
cannot be trusted and should not be
taken seriously
another um of our of our favorite and
newer sponsors charity mobile
you know uh it's there there are a lot
of
companies out there and some of the
companies that we're gonna be you know
supporting and buying
things from around the holidays uh maybe
on black friday
some of these companies many of them are
against us you know they're not on our
side in the culture and actually are
working
working against us working to undermine
us
in the culture um and that's why it's so
important when you've got
a company like charity mobile who
supports us
and and supports our cause to also
support them they are the pro-life phone
company
and uh what that means is that five
percent of your monthly plan price goes
to the pro-life
pro family charity of your choice new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping so you're getting a lot of
perks as well
along with you know helping the pro-life
cause there's no contracts there's no
termination fees they're not trying to
you know uh get you stuck in anything
you don't want to be a part of
and there's no risk with a 30-day
guarantee so at least give it a try
they've got the live customer service
based in the usa and they're given jobs
here in america as well which is great
um look you can help build a culture of
america culture of life in america
while supporting a pro-life phone
company and also getting
a great service and a great product so
it's the ultimate win-win we're talking
about great service great product
supporting the most important cause on
top of it there's just no losing with
this
so call charity mobile at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
number two this is also important
i am an adult capable of evaluating risk
and making informed choices all of the
coveted restrictions have rested on the
premise
that america is a land of children who
cannot be trusted to act with any
semblance of maturity
or discernment and it may be true that a
certain unfortunately large portion of
americans
actually could be described that way a
lot of them work in dc as it happens
quite a few reside in governor's
mansions
but i know that i'm not one of them
i know that though i may not be able to
say much else for myself
i am at least an adult with common sense
i have i have that going for me at least
the whole point of being american and
being free is that we're supposed to be
treated as
not treated as one collective whole but
rather we're meant to
have the liberty to act as individuals
the absolute best thing i can say for
the coveted restrictions
to include the thanksgiving stuff is
that these
are measures meant to restrict the
absolute
dumbest and least responsible people the
sort of person who would be
stupid enough to wake up with a fever
and a bad cough
and still have their 92 year old
grandmother over for dinner
that's the sort of person who really
causes the problem right
that's what we're really worried about
they are where the danger lies
um the idea is to shut everyone down in
order to stop
that person but again this is not how
america is supposed to be governed
and i know that i am not that person
i know not to be around people if i'm
sick and that's the case
covet or not you got a fever you're
coughing don't go out don't be with your
family you're going to spread a sickness
i know that you know that
i know to wash my hands i know to cough
into my sleeve
not to cough in someone's face or just
out into the open i know that too
why should i operate according to rules
designed for morons if
i am not one myself by the way
the powers that be basically admitted
that this was the strategy
they initially told us not to wear masks
if you remember and then they reversed
course and we were told that the initial
messaging on masks was just to stop
dumb people from hoarding all of them
they were worried that stupid people
would go out and buy all the masks for
themselves
so instead of telling us the truth or
what they perceive as the truth
they lied to everyone in order to stop
the dumb people
it's kind of a you know bomb the whole
village to kill the terrorists hiding
inside one of the hutt's strategy
which incidentally with biden in charge
we're sure to have a lot more wars and
bombings
and the media couldn't be more excited
about that by the way but that's neither
here nor there
at any rate this is all perhaps academic
anyway
all that should really need to be said
is that this is america
i'm an american the government has no
authority to tell me
who can be in my house or whether i can
be in someone else's house
i do not respect the authority the
government pretends to have on this
front
i don't respect it i don't trust its
guidelines
i don't care what it says it's sad that
it's come to this
but that's where we are so now all
that's left is to eat drink and
have a happy thanksgiving and that's
what i intend to do i hope you do as
well
let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
before we get to our five headlines
listen i think one thing we've learned
this year
is that uh anything could happen and you
know
things we aren't expecting and that's
why it's so important to be prepared and
now
is a better time than any to be prepared
with long-term
nutritional food options from ready-wise
you know with ready-wise you have
options like
emergency meals they've got freeze-dried
fruits and vegetables for convenient
on-the-go nutrition
they've also got these adventure meals
for hiking and camping if you like going
outdoors
uh so you know that's that's another
time and you want to be prepared
obviously
even if it's not necessarily an
emergency but try the adventure meals as
well they're really great
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
now due to increased demand supplies are
limited some things are going to be out
of stock and all that means is
you want to go right now and take
advantage of this at readywise.com
when government resources are strained
it can be days if not weeks before fresh
food is available
you don't want to put yourself in a
situation where you don't have what you
need what you need but you're thinking
to yourself i wish i had been prepared
by then it's going to be too late
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable do you just order online
they're going to ship
everything to you and um on top of that
as well you know what the food the food
is good um
some of these things if you think
emergency meals you're thinking oh
it's we got to sacrifice taste it's not
gonna taste very good but on top of
everything else it actually
the food tastes great so this week my
listeners can get free shipping at
readywise.com when entering walsh at
checkout or by calling 855-475-3089
brady weiss has a 90-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today
that's readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code walsh to get free
shipping today
all right by the way i uh i brought my
my sons into work a couple days ago and
it just
it it you know you you put yourself back
in the mind of a child
and uh nobody was here i had to come i
left my my computer charger here so i
came into the office
just to get it and i brought them with
it because they wanted to see where
daddy works and so i brought them in
and um and you know i'm showing them
around
showing them the studio they don't
really care about any of that the only
thing they care about is that we walk
through the break room and there's a jar
of candy
and they discover and are just
overwhelmed
by the the revelation that
there's candy at my work and i can eat
as much candy as i want
they they can they still are talking
about they couldn't get enough of that
and it just um it makes me you know it's
the innocence of childhood
and i i can remember being a kid and i i
it reminded me
as a child i used to think this i used
to think
it's unbelievable as an adult you can
you can eat all the candy you want you
can just eat candy all day
and then you get older and as an adult
you discover things like diabetes and
you know all of that so that's sort of
unfortunate okay let's move on to this
if you forgot um
if you forgot what it was like to have
the the media
fawning over the president rather than
rather than telling us that he's the
devil all the time
we've been given a stark reminder in
recent days what that's like um
as joe biden fills out his cabinet
the media is just beside itself with
glee over this
joe biden is putting a bunch of mediocre
career bureaucrats in charge again
and the media is ecstatic about it and
they want us to be excited about these
bureaucrats
bureaucrats are back let's all let's all
throw a party
one one bizarre talking point and you
know how with the media they all they'll
settle on these talking points
suspiciously all at once
and they all start saying the same thing
right so one thing they've settled on
is that um joe biden's cabinet filled
with political hacks
will somehow be not political listen
when i look at that group up there and
let's put john kerry aside because as we
know he was the democratic nominee for
president once
but they are not political they are just
career
people they have worked together for
many years
i remember jake sullivan at the at the
side of hillary clinton when she was
secretary of state
all the time and as they say they
really do reflect america they
are now being told that it is not going
to be political and joe biden is saying
these are people this is a team who is
going to tell me this team will tell me
what i need to know what not what i want
to know that
is a big change yeah that's obviously
nonsense but this is how they see it
because they see democrats as being
objectively right about everything so
there's nothing political about anything
they say whatever they say is just a
fact
it's not political meanwhile it gets way
more funding than that
um just just listen to this
to talk about joe biden's empathy in
humanity to talk about diplomacy being
back
it is all an implicit rebuke
of donald trump's foreign policy
stewardship over the last four years
that's right and then just saying that
they're going to do their jobs and
be good stewards of america's role in
this world and
focus on american diplomacy that in and
of itself um being a rebuke of president
trump is
uh underscores what we've all been
living through in the last four years
this is
a president who wanted to be more
isolationist who wanted to pull back
um what we saw today i was sitting in
that room in wilmington
um i was thinking about the fact that
joe biden in some ways
first supporters is fulfilling the
promises that he made on the campaign
trail he said he wanted to have a
cabinet
that looked like america and there were
people there on that stage of course
talking about
all of their different accolades and
their experience but they were also
talking about their families
who survived the holocaust who survived
coming from cuba and flink
communists who talked about um having
gumbo
diplomacy cooking food cooking southern
food as the united nations ambassador
thing um all of those things are what
america is about it's a melting pot the
other thing i'll just say is i was
talking to a democrat
who just said this also felt like the
avengers it felt like we're being
rescued from this
this craziness that we've all lived
through from the last four years and now
here are the superheroes to come and
save us all superheroes
they're superheroes uh but yes i'm sure
we can rely on these people to be
objective and to tell us the truth and
all the stuff we've heard over the last
four years about you know truth to power
and everything like that
holding those in power accountable
democracy
dies in darkness we we need the media
truth tellers you know all that stuff we
heard four years ago
all out the window right away and now
it's the people in charge are
superheroes
right um the problem for the media
i don't think they've they've fully
come to terms with this yet but
the fawning coverage telling us that
bureaucrats are superheroes
not only is that disgraceful and
dishonest but
the bigger problem for them is that it's
boring
nobody wants to sit and listen to you
defend the government and tell us how
great they all are
that's not nearly as fun to hear and so
the the ratings crash for the for the
media is going to be
extraordinary and i don't think they've
they fully um
come to terms with that yet but that's
that's one of the reasons why i
mentioned before
you know they're excited about bringing
some of these war hawks and and
and people back in to the um back onto
the scene
you know what they say about oh we're
going to be uh we're going to be
involved in the world again and
what joe biden said a few weeks ago
about he's going to let the rest of the
world know that america is back
what they really mean not so thinly
veiled is
we're going to be starting wars again
and the media's excited about that
you know cause that'll get the ratings
up again donald trump is great for the
raise if donald trump is gone next best
thing
have some wars and that's what the media
wants okay this is from the daily wire
it says penguin random house canada
has contracted with psychology professor
jordan peterson
to release his forthcoming book beyond
order 12 more rules for life
on march 20 uh 2021
but the um the development has
reportedly also upset some staffers at
the publishing house according to vice
news
which spoke to four employees at penguin
random house canada
the publishing house held a town hall
style meeting where staff members aired
their grievances about peterson in the
upcoming book
some even cried about it they were
crying
about jordan peterson at work one
employee told vice that people were
crying in their meeting
in the meeting about how jordan peterson
has affected their lives
and noted that one person at the meeting
also claimed that their father had been
radicalized
by the self-help professor the employees
said the company since june has been
doing all these
anti-racist and allyship things and then
publishing peterson's book completely
goes against this
it just makes all of their previous
efforts seem completely performative
uh an interview with vice another
employee called peter called peterson an
icon of white supremacy
and as such suggested that the content
of his book doesn't matter
um okay a couple of things here
first of all you know i'm not an expert
in the publishing business but i do know
that the vast majority of books that a
publisher like random house puts out
don't make any money
they make all their money from a few
books
that are put out every year a book like
jordan jordan penis's book is going to
sell
you know a billion copies or whatever
they make all their money from this
and so in other words if these idiots
actually succeeded
in stopping their publishing house from
publishing jordan peterson
a lot of them are going to lose their
jobs because that's how they're getting
paid this year is from that jordan
peterson book
and a couple of other books of course
they don't realize that because
they don't even understand their own
business because they're morons
but the other thing the main thing of
course is is um
this is just a good a good tip for all
employers i think
um if you have someone crying at work
i think and this could be a delicate
situation
best way to handle it is to you know
take them by the shoulder
lead them into your to your office if
you're the employer if you're their boss
and sit them down you know hand them a
tissue
and just and i would just and i would
just look at them very
with very kind eyes and say
get the hell out of here you
embarrassing baby
you're fired and then the next step the
next really important step is
especially if they're crying about
jordan peterson make sure to gather all
of the other employees
you know while that person gets their
box of stuff together have all the other
places stand
and just and as they're walking out
point and laugh as they walk out in
tears
that's the appropriate response to
somebody crying at work
completely unacceptable in general to
cry at work
over something like this especially so
now i did say this on twitter yesterday
and i i was i was informed by some
women that um you know to have a rule of
no crying at work is unfair to women
because
you know women have to cry every once in
a while at work it happens
and i understand that so i think what
the rules should be and i'm going to
talk to hr here at daley wire about this
but because of course they care about
what i think the rules should be
so i think what the rules should be is
men you can never cry at work period you
cry at work you're done
and you're banning you're you're fired
and you're banished from from
all jobs in the future but for women uh
you can cry once per fiscal quarter and
so what i would say is plan ahead
uh just make it make it count if you
feel like you want to have additional
cries
you can apply for a waiver ahead of time
with hr
and it'll take three to five business
days to process and when that comes
through you can have your
your cry so i think those were those are
what the rules should be
all right um article from cnn here
i guess looking on the bright side the
headline is
covid might mean fewer family political
fights over thanksgiving
and i'm not even going to bother to read
this
because it doesn't matter but this is
the you see this every single year
and a little bit of a different twist on
it this year but usually you get these
articles every year about
how to survive thanksgiving with your
conservative uncle how do how do
how to navigate political fights at the
how to avoid political arguments at
thanksgiving all these kinds of
articles and now we're supposed to say
oh it's good we're not having
thanksgiving because then we don't have
the political arguments
i don't under i don't get it like th
this is the whole
fun of thanksgiving isn't it am i crazy
or is is everybody else i always find
myself asking that
for me this is the whole fun of it you
get your family together and
you know you eat something you eat a
meal and you argue about politics
or theology or like anything but you got
to have some kind of debate some kind of
argument
how boring would your family have to be
if you don't have any political
arguments
and this is where people people say well
the things you never talk about
religion and politics that's all i talk
about
what the hell else would you talk about
sports i guess we could throw that in so
yeah sure you talk other than that what
else is there to talk about
i'm just i'm so grateful i'm not in the
same family as uh
as so many of these people that have
this attitude number four so eric
garcetti mayor of los angeles
far left wacko and um
he's another mayor who's you know
completely bought in of course to the
leftist
racial narrative he's bent over
backwards for
blm and rioters letting them do whatever
they want
um like all other democrat mayors of
course let's
so he's done all that and he's been
mayor for i don't know
i think five or six years or something
let's check in
with blm to see how they're thanking him
for his efforts
how's it going over with them how are
they thanking him uh let's uh let's
listen here it is
for his entire reign as mayor is
silence black voices right forget it
he wants us to be silent as he continues
to feed
a police department that is one of the
most murderous
in the entire nation
well that answers the question no
surprise there and you probably picked
up from the context clues but the
bleeped out word they were they were
saying
f eric garcetti ch chant to get into a
bullhorn
um i i think what they these those are
blm protesters uh protesting again
and they were trying to ensure i believe
that eric garcetti is not appointed
to any positions in um joe biden's white
house
because that because eric said he's
racist he's an
ally of white supremacists this far-left
wacko mayor of los angeles is it is
now an hour it's basically a nazi
himself
once again we see that there's there's
no satisfying the left you cannot
satisfy
no matter what you do you can't satisfy
them
and you could you could say that there's
you know you have sort of some of that
on both sides where you've got the
ideological purists who are who are
never happy and are always going to be
critical of you
but that's not real on the right you
know it is
possible i mean i'm i'm kind of one of
those ideological peers
and yeah i do hate most politicians even
on our own side
but at the same time it is possible on
the right to you know
if a public figure a politician
a president a mayor whatever um you know
could basically do the right thing and
we can
basically be satisfied with that maybe
not completely satisfied but we could
say all right you know you're on the
right
path here on the left though no
there's nothing you can do it does not
matter they will never
ever be happy but of course guys like
eric garcetti will
continue trying um finally reading from
gizmodo um we had to before i guess
the year wraps up we had to have another
potential alien
alien related news and so here we have
this
and you can look at it if you're
watching on the video right now
officers from the utah department of
public safety discovered a shiny
metallic monolith
in rural utah's red rock country on
november 18th
while surveying bighorn sheep by
helicopter the monolith has drawn
comparisons to the
uh black monolith in stanley kubrick's
1968 film 2001 of space odyssey
and the helicopter crew said there's no
obvious indication of who may have
placed the object there
the utah agency published photos and
videos to his website showing the team's
investigation of the strange-looking
object the monolith appears to have
three sides and measures roughly 10 to
12 feet high
according to the the people who found it
the crew
did not note or did note that it's
firmly planted in the ground
and didn't appear to have been dropped
from above
so the article goes on from there you
can you can look at the
footage of it they were yeah these they
were going they were
surveying they were um in in helicopters
and they happened to spot this thing out
in the
they're not telling us where it is
because they don't want sightseers it's
out like
way out in the wilderness and they don't
want people going to try to find it
dying of starvation on the way um but
it's somewhere out in the wilderness and
this thing is there
10 to 12 feet high this big metallic
structure
i saw this on i don't know if this is
true or not but i did see on twitter so
i'm going to report
potentially fake news um there are some
pictures going around on on social media
claiming
you know these people have been
reviewing satellite data and stuff going
back over the years
and the claim is that this thing has
been there for like
five or six years and nobody knows how
it got there
and this is the first time someone
noticed it
kind of interesting to me though if
we're gonna come up with theories
it it clearly looks to me
to be an alien porta potty
you know the aliens brought it here
because it's a long trip makes sense you
gotta have somewhere to do your business
um and then they came and they set up
their port-a-potty they went out for a
hike or something around the desert
checking things out came back and found
the earthlings climbing all over their
outhouse
and they just sort of looked at each
other and slowly backed away
got on their spaceships and left that's
my that's my scientific theory based on
the data
but uh maybe eventually we'll find out
who put it there and why
for daily cancellation you know you
always hear people talking about gold
and how it's so important to hedge your
investments with gold
which sounds great but the problem is
that it involves buying gold which
is expensive if you haven't heard uh so
here's something new
as the price of gold has been
skyrocketing lately there's a new way to
buy gold through a company called acre
acre lets you subscribe to gold
for as little as 30 a month you're
subscribing to the gold bars you pay
each month
once your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they discreetly ship
acre gold to your house
and they're taking care of your your
shipment um
which means it's going to be it's going
to get safe and sound and discreet to
your door
acre designs their gold in california
sources their gold from one of the
largest mints in
switzerland acre provides industry-first
packaging that looks and feels more
expensive
than other gold alternatives and also uh
by the way
you know if you want to go up the 30 a
month acre just recently introduced the
new
100 per month subscription for their 5
gram
gold bar and you just you want to take
advantage of this but but listen to this
part of it
and this is especially something to take
advantage of you got to visit get acre
gold dot com slash walsh
you can start investing in physical gold
today but you also want to use this url
because acre is giving away a gold bar
and to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post
why you should be the recipient and men
should mention
at get underscore acre when you do that
maybe you get the free gold bar on top
of that again that's getagergold.com
walsh and we want to thank anchor gold
for supporting
supporting the show one other note as we
uh
get to our final daily cancellation
before the thanksgiving break
uh and as thanksgiving is almost here
and we're getting ready for black friday
uh after that you know we had a black
friday deal here at the daily wire last
year and it was
a huge success but we've been
consistently adding more features and
products to our membership program
we're really excited about all the stuff
we're adding so to name a few things
we've added more exclusive readers past
content um our insider and above members
can now stream our content on apple tv
and roku
which is exciting because of all the new
content that's uh that's also available
including the michael noll show will be
uh five days a week starting friday
december 4th
your account also now comes with custom
badges that you can
that can earn that you can earn by
participating in daily wire events
if you're an all access member you can
take part in our all access discussions
those are the
live streamed uh discussions we have
with the hosts
and also you the the the viewer you also
get two leftist tiers tumblers
um early access to our daily wire merch
there's just so many benefits you could
hardly list them all
we're also continuing to add new
features and products like the entire
prageru catalog is going to be added
we've got and candace owens maybe you've
heard joining
and so her content will be available as
well needless to say we're very excited
about it
uh but you don't want to miss this black
friday deal so take advantage of that
now so today we're going to cancel this
man ryan dorsey
and all his kind all his ilk he's a
baltimore city council mayor uh
member i should say and i don't mean
that kind that's not the kind i'm
referring to
though sure we can cancel the baltimore
city council i guess why not they really
haven't been doing much good recently
and by recently i mean for the past i
don't know five decades or so
but that's not the point today the point
is this tweet from dorsey
um and there's a picture there of a
fedex truck and a bike lane in the city
and it says
quote hey fedex i told your driver here
to get out of the bike lane he was
obstructing which i happened to be
biking in
his response was get a car
now needless to say this fedex driver is
awesome ryan dorsey on the other hand is
the lamest
dork this side of justin trudeau not
only is he riding a bike
and bitching at a delivery guy but after
the delivery guy verbally backhands him
he posts his own humiliation on social
media thinking he'll get sympathy from
the public rather than
the relentless mockery and scorn he
deserves quick tip here even for people
who aren't lame dorks
when the internet has to choose between
sympathy or scorn
it will always choose scored always
so keep that in mind or learn it the
hard way as
ryan dorsey has but this behavior is
what i would expect from dorsey given
that he is a cyclist
cyclists and i mean those who ride bikes
on the street
and you know streets those things where
cars go
those kinds of cyclists are a cursed
breed
they are among the worst people on earth
the absolute
dregs of humanity no one no offense
intended
every time i'm driving down a busy
street and traffic is backed up for
miles
because everyone has to navigate around
some weirdo on a bike
i am perplexed anew how is this even
legal
i think to myself why are we allowing
people to ride their bikes on roads
where cars are supposed to go now i get
that you want to exercise that's fine
but why are you exercising in the damned
street
during rush hour i like to exercise too
i'm not going to set up a bench press on
the freeway i'm not going to take an ab
roller down to the nearest intersection
hey give me a minute i got three more
sets all right hold on
why why won't i do that because i'm not
a lunatic and i care about other people
sort of at least i'm not going to go out
of my way to make their commute longer
and more stressful than it already
is i'm not gonna do that cyclists do
that now what gets me about the bike
riders
is their sense of entitlement it's not
just that they have the audacity
to play with their toy in the street
it's that they they get angry at you
for being there they act like you are
inconveniencing them
they act like you just jumped on the
same elliptical that they were using at
the gym
but the street is not your elliptical
it's a street
if you want an elliptical go use an
elliptical and if you want to play with
your bike
go to a park or a bike trail in the
woods
or maybe daddy can take you down to the
tennis courts near the playground
so you can ride your big wheel around
maybe that or better yet ditch the bike
and be an adult
find a hobby that isn't as likely to
make you a victim of vehicular
manslaughter
just a thought now i know i'll be told
that some people use bikes as
transportation
not as toys or exercise equipment fine
but the street
is for a certain type of transportation
vehicle transportation if you can use
your bike as transportation on the
street
then why can't i use a pogo stick why
can't i pogo down to work
maybe the city will be maybe the city
can build me a pogo lane
just for me you know why can't i take
this office chair right here it's got
wheels
i just roll it down the highway why
can't i go out to 10th avenue and do
cartwheels for five blocks i'm just it's
just transportation
hey this is how i get to work all right
i cartwheel to work
we all have our methods why not because
again that would be insane
and the road isn't made for it the road
in fact is made so that five thousand
pounds hunk of five thousand pound hunks
of metal
can fly down them at high speeds that's
what it's there for
it's not made so that middle-aged
vegetarians and spandex shorts can burn
off some calories
on the way to work commuting is not a
time for burning calories anyway
that's the other annoying thing the rest
of us are jamming donuts into our fat
faces while we sit in traffic
and stew in our own body fat and misery
and you're riding by all brisk and
healthy and happy
it's irritating especially around
thanksgiving
and it's grotesque and it's dangerous
and it's an inconvenience to me so
cyclists are canceled take an uber next
time
no more bikes they're not allowed that's
it
and on that note hope you all have a
happy thanksgiving with your families
and i'll talk to you next week have a
great day
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
joe biden promises amnesty for 11
million illegal aliens the media deny
that biden's cabinet will be political
and half the country doesn't plan to
take the coronavirus vaccine check it
out on the michael knowles show